hey guys so it's August and I've been
doing Veda over on my other iJustine
channel which I'll be alternating vlogs
being posted here in my main channel and
on my second channel you've been a big
fan of this show called everything but
the news so today they came and shot an
episode for their series here and while
they were shooting I shot this little
video clip for them to show them how to
make a vlog I was dying so I thought I
would share with you guys that actual
clip which I'll post after this and
Jenna you were upstairs during all of
this it was quite warm you might have a
little cameo and sharpen my Shark Week
videos oh I forgot about that
oh my gosh I have to get that footage
off of that camera oh you guys look good
not really
but it's okay oh there you go that's
good up down down down down sugar be
short or not swim up the surface oh the
no okay this is good this is a
good show okay guys swim I'm not in the
shot you're you don't see you in it I
don't think I'm um yeah we're showing
them like my green screen and just
showing them how to shoot at YouTube
videos and it's so funny I can't wait
until you see the episode I hope it
turns out well I'm not sure but if it's
on par with the rest of their episodes
it's gonna be awesome
we should play Mario Kart oh you are
recording okay we got okay so it's like
your posture okay sorry I'm really
sweaty that's right you're sitting
really close yes that's gonna feel like
I mean that's better yeah okay well not
maybe just a little bit over say she's a
tad bit but you don't have to be
touching it like that sooo close that's
my look we can have some space yeah but
I want to I don't know I mean you know
so I would have an equal amount of space
over here just as it is over here this
feels good this is good so okay so hey
guys oh this is my friend Steve let's
Noah over there you guys can't see you
wanna come show them show them you know
ah hello
okay so you do a show or something yeah
I do a I do a show for who do I look at
here do I look at you well I mean we're
talking two peoples I'm looking at my
socks on the screen we can you look into
the camera look at the screen no that's
your biggest legend looking at the
screen always never look here oh my gosh
no that's like YouTube's do that great
hey YouTube this is Steve and I'm here
with iJustine who is you know and me you
probably don't know our show is called
everything but the news on PBS Digital
Studios PBS it's a fantastic show so you
guys don't know what you didn't know
again there's no come back come back
people can you just even just bring them
in club I know just keep a hold them in
for a minute
just this knows we've known each other
since we were born and Nova Scotia oh
you guys are from Canada from Canada no
I say silly
awkward so actually so this is gonna be
a part of my video today I do well it's
August right now I don't know when you
guys are gonna post this cuz like when I
do YouTube videos like this is gonna be
posted today we don't have as fast
turnaround time to see you because we're
doing the Veda vlog every day in August
favor Veda vlog vlog every day in August
Veda there's also like that you say what
it when you say what everyone's right
yeah know that yeah that's it
okay I made a video but what else should
we talk about I mean what did you what
did you have for lunch I had a an egg
sandwich yeah I had a tuna wrap and I
meant I made I know I know what I want
to talk about I made script would you
make scrambled eggs I don't want to put
I don't wanna put this background cover
real people it's like we cover tech and
we cover culture and you know we cover
what's going on and and we have sort of
our own little split like Oprah well
it's interesting that that was your
takeaway from what I said it's nothing
like what like Oprah did like stuff like
that she talked to people she didn't
really do that news yeah I don't maybe a
little more like Tom Schneider I don't
know who that is
I'm gonna take off this hoodie each
other year back on now okay guys thanks
for watching I'll see you
yeah thank you so much whoever you are
for watching this and then if you yeah
well that's amazing app from your phone
nest air cool hot bye go go check out
their channel because I think yeah we
know one you know what it's looking I
think they need they need some me might
imagine
no what are you saying nothing he's a
watcher later bye you guys not let's do
one more here yeah I look stupid I don't
like it there's two do it again you have
a really bad selfie angle haha alright
and that's a wrap on our shoot today so
so how was it did you did you enjoy it
it was super fun I'm not used to being
in front of the camera so yeah awkward
but I know it was great
Steve was a champ we're all really so
what's one yeah come on admit you were
you were great we've ever had really I'm
gonna tell all the other guests well
thanks guys um we're talking about the
show some will see miss today this is
posting today yeah well you can watch me
to do this you can follow me on Twitter
Steve eg 617 stuff ste v ee ee ee ee so
at CVG i will type it everything just
google everything i use everything but
the news that's it that's the easiest
way hashtag you EDM it'll come out not
today it's the only next month it's fine
yeah I'll tweet it to you guys yeah I'm
excited okay um bye bye I'm gonna pick
up where you left off alright so I had a
fun day shooting and now I'm not sure
I'm really tired cats here her dog will
her second dog we don't really know
what's wrong with it but it's it the
doctors right now she's on a phone call
so maybe we will get the update and see
what's new bad is downstairs Jenna there
yeah the beta today is gonna be a little
interesting I was trying to teach Steve
hell of a log yeah well you probably
already saw that clip so you know what
happened
pinched we were like cats here and we
were talking was huge
it's really bad that's it she said no we
were like happier but she's on the phone
and then we're like okay Castle II just
want to just know guys hi we hope see my
puppy kapa haka we don't go topless okay
yeah we do we are all sending our love
my Veda